lisa's in san antonio lisa how can we
help
hi dave thanks for having me sure what's
up
my questions got a lot of twists here um
i am currently staying with my mother
who's 88 and she has dementia
taking care of her i have a home
that i'm about to sell
and what we want to do is my sister and
i
purchase a new home where we can take
care of her
um my income take care of your sister or
your mother
my mother our mother okay all right and
you're living in who's home now taking
care of her
we're in i'm in mom's home and why are
you selling that
um well we we thought if we
my sister all three of us have homes
that means mom myself and sister
uh if we each sold all of these these
three homes and moved into a newer home
we were selling mom's home because it's
aging and a lot to repairs foundation
and the list goes on so we were thinking
well maybe
we should we're living in the home that
is yours
it's being rented out now and the renter
wants to buy
okay all right would it work for you and
your mom to live in
it's a two bedroom room it's a smaller
home
for you and your mom to live in it
would yeah um and so what was your
so how old is your mom mama's 88 just
turned 88.
and what stage is she in on dementia
uh she's in the advanced stage um
besides the dementia her physical health
is
okay no problems there okay
all right and so your question is about
what your question is exactly what
new home purchase is uh
it would it be feasible or a good idea
if
we took care of a mom in a newer home
with my sister's income in addition to
mine of course my income is
significantly
lower because i'm the primary caretaker
so with the sell of my home i can
completely pay off
every debt that i have and
move into your sister's home move into a
new home
no no my sister's home would be sold my
home would be sold
and mom's home would be sober but the
new home is purchased by your sister
who's the only one that has an income to
buy it right
yes i would we would be co oh
okay yeah and of course her
at my credit score right now is great um
hers is lower but she has the income how
old are you and i'm
i am 51. okay 5-1
correct when you're 6-1
and mom's in heaven and you live with
your sister
in a partnership in a home that doesn't
sound fun to me
okay okay
i'm looking out a little bit further in
the future
past some pain that none of us want to
look at
right right but mom's going to heaven
someday
right and um when that happens
the net result is that we have two
sisters that are co-signers
and they may or may not want to stay in
that house together they may or may not
want to keep it together
i would prefer one of you own it and the
other one have a rental arrangement with
the
for instance i would prefer that you
just be a tenant to your sister
and then later on if mom passes you
could go on and have your life
and your sister go and have her life and
we don't have a piece of real estate
standing between us in life
could you all live in your sister's home
i don't think we've lost that option
have we
the existing sisters home could you just
all move into that
the existing sister has a tenant
and there's not an extra room in the
house
see if the tenant was gone would it be
okay
let's be super tight okay all right
it would be a real pressured push yeah i
guess
yeah so um well i i can
i i if if um you were my little sister
i'm 60 i would tell you to
i love you your care for your mom and i
love that all of you are willing to pile
in together and care for each other and
mom
i think that's going to wear thin a
decade from now
and real estate's an awfully permanent
decision to make
together so if your sister has the
ability to do this deal and rent to you
and your mom
and you and your mom sell all three of
you sell and she buys a better house
i would go with that but i don't want
you co-signing and i would not tell you
to co-sign
and i would not tell you to be a partner
in this deal because i think the
long-term implications are going to be
hurtful
this is the dave ramsey show